we brought the sad news on this program
a couple of times how many American
cities all of a sudden seem to resemble
slums some of you may have trouble
visualizing what that means and this is
for you after last night's program we
were sent this picture by a viewer who
lives and works in the city of San
Francisco
it shows the sidewalk outside his office
littered with by our count more than 30
syringes and other drug paraphernalia
this is not in some abandoned lot or
underneath the freeway overpass it's
right outside the offices of Spotify a
top tech company in downtown San
Francisco that's right across the street
from we work it's one block away from
Zen res these are all tech companies and
three blocks from tech giants Twitter
and uber these are some of the richest
companies in the richest industry in the
richest city in the United States and
their employees work in a circus of
trash and drugs and the question is do
elites even care and the answer of
course is you know they don't US cities
aren't just plagued by homeless drug
addicts but also by deadly Central
American gangs it's not propaganda it is
real we've got new numbers out today
about the extent of ms-13 that's the
primarily Salvadoran gang that has
become the deadliest organized crime
ring in the country
Jessica Vaughan is director of policy at
the Center for Immigration Studies and
she joins us with those numbers Jessica
thanks for coming on glad to be with you
so ms-13 despite it sounds like efforts
from the federal government is
metastasizing is that what the numbers
show well it is it some people have been
very dismissive of all the attention to
this gang but it has rebuilt itself it's
it's not a homegrown gang it was formed
by people who came from Central America
decades ago illegally so that was a
failure in border security but ice and
other law enforcement agencies were able
to stifle it for a while there but in
recent years it's really rebounded
because of this it took advantage of
this surge of unaccompanied minors
that's been going on for several years
and and also the lack of immigration
enforcement so they have come back with
a vengeance and this is not just petty
gang violence nuisance crimes we're
talking murders hundreds of murders the
ms-13 members have been arrested for and
it's a scourge in a number of
communities that so give us a sense of
the scale so we think of ms-13 as
primarily in Los Angeles County in
suburban Virginia outside Washington
maybe Chicago it spread though tell us
what that looks like at a certain point
in time the gang decided to almost open
up franchises around the country places
like Long Island Boston Charlotte North
Carolina as you said the suburbs of
Washington DC because this is a gang
that's controlled from El Salvador and
the cliques in the United States do send
money back to El Salvador to help to
support the whole gang and so at a
certain point in time the leaders put
pressure on those members here in the
United States to kick it up a notch and
start doing more and bring in some more
people from Central America recruit more
from these kids who've recently arrived
they do extortion home invasion right
sex trafficking prostitution and and
murder to prove themselves to each other
and to intimidate others in the
community
and and we found that they were active
in 22 states just in the last few years
and concentrated as I said in those
areas that experienced a lot of the
illegal arrivals from Central America
when it's it's urban its rural as well
in some places that have never had these
kind this kind of a gang presence before
and it's difficult for for them and we
should point out the division what the
victims are almost all immigrants from
something that immigrants rights
advocates so-called
ignore ironically Jessica thank you for
coming on and telling us that I
appreciate it
thank you